un encuentro por la amistad y la paz Así
presentó el ministro chino de asuntos
exteriores la visita la próxima semana
del presidente chino a
Moscú
basándose en los principios de no
alineamiento no confrontación y no
ataque a terceros las dos partes
practicarán multilateralismo Genuino
promoverán la democratización de las
relaciones internacionales construirán
un mundo multipolar mejorarán la
gobernanza global y contribuirán al
desarrollo y progreso del mundo china
mantendrá su posición objetiva y justa
sobre la crisis ucraniana y desempeñará
un papel constructivo en la promoción de
las conversaciones de paz el crimen
precisó que los dos líderes discutirán
la cooperación estratégica entre sus
países según algunos especialistas el
mandatario chino que podría también
reunirse con su homólogo ucraniano Busca
posicionarse como facilitador del
diálogo entre kiev y Moscú tras haber
mediado en la reanudación de las
relaciones entre Irán y Arabia
si no quiere encontrar formas de dar la
impresión que esto es parte de una
diplomacia de paz y por supuesto lo más
importante es que lo que no ha estado
dispuesto a hacer que es hablar con el
presidente ucraniano parece que tendrá
lugar después de Esta visita
Por otra parte el anuncio del viaje de
She se produce cuando se ha anunciado la
puesta en marcha del acuerdo entre
Australia Estados Unidos y el Reino
Unido con este pacto conocido como aucus
los tres aliados pretenden aumentar su
poder de disuación y de ataque para
contrarrestar la influencia china en el
mar de China meridional Beijing criticó
por su parte lo que califica como una
política de bloque y de enfrentamiento
entre bandos liderada por Estados Unidos